the planets moons and stars make up less
than 5% of all the mass in the universe
the rest lies in the realm of absolute
darkness the dark universe is the
invisible yet dominating component of
the cosmos it includes a substance
called dark matter and a force called
dark energy while little is known about
either each helps us understand the
universe beyond what the eye can see
Dark Matter makes up about 25% of mass
in the universe but its composition is
still unknown the substance neither
emits nor reflects light and because of
that it cannot be seen the existence of
dark matter can be inferred based on its
gravitational pull on the visible
universe according to some scientists
this force is what prevents stars within
galaxies from drifting away
Dark Matter may have also played a role
in the creation of the cosmos after the
Big Bang dark matter formed a network of
filaments across the universe and in
this network the first stars and
galaxies were born not much is known
about dark matter but even less is known
about dark energy dark energy is a
mysterious force that fills the space
between objects it makes up about 70% of
mass in the universe
plus it has a repulsive property that
counteracts the force of gravity the
reason for dark Energy's existence is
unclear one theory states that it's the
fifth force of nature yet another says
may help explain why the universe is
expanding in his theory of general
relativity Albert Einstein considered a
repulsive force similar to dark energy
that pushed space and particles apart
called the cosmological constant the
variable may provide clues for the
expansion of space and time much about
the dark universe is left to be
discovered but with every theory and
technological development secrets of the
invisible cosmos will come closer to
being revealed
[Music]